le County Jail you know people describe
it as a dungeon hell on earth it surely
is on December 9 2013 the Los Angeles
County Sheriff's Department got some
very bad news from the US Attorney's
Office we unsealed five criminal cases
that alleged criminal conduct by a total
of 18 current or former deputies county
sheriff's department this scandal has
been developing over the years it's not
as if these indictments came down in a
vacuum Peter Elias burg is legal
director at the ACLU of Southern
California the organization is tracked
abuses inside the LA County Jail for
decades the Los Angeles County Jail
system is the largest Jail system in the
country it is run by the Los Angeles
County Sheriff's Department three of
those indictments involved either
excessive use of force covering up that
use of force or otherwise trying to
obstruct justice one of the indictments
involved an effort to basically move an
FBI informant around the jails to hide
him from the FBI to try to intimidate or
otherwise interfere with FBI agents from
doing their and their their jobs after
the charges Sheriff Lee Baca maintained
that the department was not experiencing
systemic problems no perfect law
enforcement there is no institutional
problem within the Sheriff's Department
when it comes to correcting itself
federal government doesn't do a lot of
oversight over local law enforcement so
when the sheriff says oh there's no
institutional problem here because this
is just some tiny number of people you
know you're never gonna find a law
enforcement agency but the majority of
people are doing terrible things that's
not gonna happen
but when you have a teen who are
federally indicted that's a major major
problem and this isn't just you know
deputies we have lieutenants we have
sergeants those who are supervising
these deputies Esther Lim is the
director of the jail's project at the
ACLU she frequently monitors the jail
for confinement conditions and proper
medical services LA County Jail
you know people describe it as a dungeon
hell on earth it surely is limb
witnessed a beating inside the jail
while visiting an inmate in 2011 the
deputies were not a part of the 18
officers recently charged but the
incident speaks to the culture inside
the jail's walls as I'm talking to this
inmate I hear noises that sound like
like someone's fighting so I look out
and peer through the window out to the
staging area of Twin Towers of that
particular floor and I look to my left I
see two deputies and they are beating
and kneeing and eventually tasering this
individual so yelling stop fighting stop
resisting and I'm looking at at the the
inmate and he's lying on the ground and
he's not moving so to me when I'm seeing
that I think he's unconscious the entire
time that I'm watching this the two
deputies that are beating host inmate
they don't know that I'm watching them
so so I thought you know what this is
inappropriate this is obviously an
excessive use of force
so I banged on the window to get their
attention to actually get them to stop
and then they didn't do anything they
either didn't hear me or they were maybe
too involved or but yet they didn't
respond to to my hitting the window and
this violent culture inside the jail
isn't just directed at inmates it's
directed to visitors to one of the
individuals Gaborik Rio he was a visitor
to men Central Jail and he was beaten
severely by the Sheriff's Department
personnel I'm in a room with all these
caches beating up on me I blacked out
and I thought the worst wasn't happening
where I'll just end up dying in there
Elias Berg says the corruption could
easily move beyond the jails most of the
deputies who start their careers in the
Los Angeles Sheriff's Department go out
and become patrol deputies they patrol
the unincorporated areas of Los Angeles
many jurisdictions or cities within LA
county hire the Sheriff's Department to
provide patrol so I think it's important
to recognize that what people learn
abuses falsifying records engaging in
excessive force what they learn in the
jail's will show up on the streets and
when the Sheriff's Department is doing
patrol certainly the federal government
has said the investigation continues
they will take the investigation whether
the evidence leads but some of the
behavior that's delineated in these
indictments for example moving a person
around the jail who is known to be an
FBI informant that's a really big deal
it seems to me that people higher up
probably knew and probably were the ones
who directed this behavior I don't know
that for a fact but I just think it's
you know
you found out that somebody who was just
an accountant at GM and you know in that
there was this major financial scandal
at GM you probably say it wasn't just
directed by the accountant that people
up higher up in the food chain must have
known and I think that there's a good
chance that that's the case here and I
think that there is at least a
possibility that what will happen
whether it be more indictments in the
indictments will be of people who are
higher ranking in the department